salut tous les ans depuis 2007 je vous
fais une vidéo sur la définition du
mentalisme compris quoi c'est pas dit je
pense qu'on a encore des choses que vous
ne savez pas des grand secret un savoir
que personne ne peut dévoiler étant nous
allons parler en toute fin de vidéo
voilà aujourd'hui j'ai invité quatre
personnes dont trois mentalist à me
donner leur définition du mentalisme
avec nous viktor vincent que vous
connaissez peut-être de la télévision
rémy larrose que vous connaissez
peut-être de ses conférences tedx luc
langevin cannes star au canada et que
vous avez déjà vu sur ma chaîne et à la
télévision et clément ferai ce que vous
connaissez peut-être d'internés c'est
important car comme chaque mentalist a
sa propre définition le fait de les
mixer ensemble à donner une définition
plus large que la mienne que vous
connaissez déjà comme le dit loïc mais
que je vais vous m en fiche de la
description tu vois comment tu sais le
mentaliste est aussi allé je laisse les
quatre personnes en question se
présenter et nous dire comment ils sont
arrivés à s'intéresser au mental je
m'appelle viktor vincent je suis
mentaliste et je m'intéresse au
mentalisme depuis que j'ai 10 septembre
ça remonte à quelques années maintenant
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui m'a fait
des expériences complètement dingue et
j'ai absolument pas compris ce qu'il
avait fait alors j'ai trouvé ça
complètement magique et ce sont ces
émotions là que j'ai envie de donner aux
autres voilà pourquoi je me suis
intéressé au mentalisme bonjour mon nom
et luc langevin ill je suis un
illusionniste canadiens plus précisément
québécois j'ai 36 ans
bonjour à tous je m'appelle rémi
larrousse et je suis mentaliste
j'ai commencé le mentalisme à l'âge de
12 ans j'ai vu un magicien dans un
cirque qui a réalisé des expériences de
mentalisme j'ai été totalement bluffé
totalement étonné c'est devenu une
passion et ensuite un métier je
m'appelle clément fraises j'ai 22 ans et
je suis également mentalist je viens de
marseille
si l est parisien qui regarde cette
vidéo c'est une petite ville dans le sud
de la france ce tricot alors nous allons
passer à la définition du mentalisme et
à quoi cela pourrait servir encore une
fois je ne vous ressert pas ma
définition la vidéo de l'année dernière
est assez exhaustive et vous l'avez en
lien dans la description toute manière
donc ça va
tu as oublié la fiche tu vois loïc c'est
beaucoup trop fort pour moi voyons
plutôt du côté de victor de l'udc et de
rémy et de clémence je dis souvent que
le mentalisme c'est un mélange de choses
rationnelles pour créer des choses qui
semblent irrationnelles comme la lecture
de penser ou la prédiction de l'avenir
évidemment je n'ai aucun pouvoir
surnaturel j'aurais bien aimé mais
malheureusement c'est pas car pour moi
le mentalisme est un peu la rencontre
parfaite entre l'illusionnisme et les
sciences humaines c'est un mélange
d'illusions de psychologie d'hypnose de
nemo technique et de tout ce qu'on peut
mettre dedans jusqu'à faire déborder la
trousse pour pouvoir bluffer le cerveau
humain qui disons le est quand même la
machine la plus un parfaite qui soit un
mental est selon moi c'est un
illusionniste ou un magicien mais
spécialisé dans les numéros qui ont un
lien avec l'esprit humain et l'intellect
humain donc tout ce qui est lecture de
penser prédictions de lavenère
manipulation de l'esprit humain crif
c'est d'utiliser ses cinq sens pour
donner l'illusion d'un sixième le
mentalisme est une branche de la magie
une spécialité de l'illusionnisme le
magicien réalise des choses étonnantes
qui semble impossible par exemple
lorsqu'il vols ou lorsqu'il levitte
on sait qui a certainement peut-être des
filous dépouillé qu'ils l'aident à
l'éviter alors que le mentaliste réalise
des choses étonnantes qui semble
possible lorsqu'il lit dans les pensées
de quelqu'un pour deviner un dessin on
se demande si il décrypte le non-verbal
lorsqu'il révèle un mot penser dans un
livre on se demande s'il n'a pas une
mémoire phénoménale et j'aime bien dire
aussi que le mentalisme sait écouter
l'autre même lorsqu'il ne parle pas je
sens que c'est plutôt une bonne
définition tout cas sa définition mal me
plaît le fait de me dire qu'on peut
aller vers les autres et les comprendre
sans forcément avoir besoin de leur
parler c'est plutôt de bonnes nouvelles
ce qui est intriguant avec le mentalisme
c'est qu'on se demande toujours si ce
que fait le mentaliste est réelle ou si
cela repose sur des trucages
en réalité le mentaliste utilise des
techniques issues de l'illusionnisme
mais aussi d'autres disciplines comme
les mathématiques la mémoire ou la
psychologie
je suis assez content d'avoir initié
cette vidéo bat vraiment mais c'est
quand même la première fois que
plusieurs mentalist mettent leur
définition en commun ce qui commence à
permettre de dégager une espèce de
définition globale que je vais essayer
de résumer d'ailleurs à la fin de cette
vidéo et avant de continuer je vais vous
laisser quelques secondes pour vous
abonner à la
n en cliquant sur abonnement puis
cliquez sur la cloche ce que comme ça si
vous revenez sur youtube et que j'ai
sorti une vidéo vous la verrez dans vos
suggestions à les y voilà
mais pour mieux comprendre leur
définition les autres en italie je leur
ai aussi demandé dans quel cadre
il pratiquait le mentalisme je pratique
l'art du mentalisme en spectacle dans
les théâtres mais aussi en entreprise où
je donne des conférences dans lesquels
j'explique comment notre cerveau peut
tomber dans certaines erreurs de
perception certains biais cognitif que
j'utilise en tant que mentalist pour
surprendre le public sur scène j'ai la
chance d'exercer mon métier un peu
partout au théâtre évidemment avec avec
les spectacles c'est l'occupation
principale mais je le fais aussi dans
des événements un peu plus privée
parfois pour des pour des lancements
d'entreprise ou des choses comme ça et
j'ai la chance aussi le faire aussi un
peu la télévision et c'est toujours
agréable de faire des expériences à des
gens qu'on connaît sans connaître qu'on
connaît de loin comme ça et je présente
ses numéros un peu partout à la télé
autant au canada français au québec
qu'en france et dans la francophonie
auto donc je me suis produit sur tf1 ou
à radio canada au québec pour ce qui est
de la télévision également sur le web
mais également aussi beaucoup sur scène
autant au québec qu'en france
ok donc certains pratiquent le
mentalisme en tant que divertissement
sur scène dans une forme qui se
rapproche de l'illusionnisme et d'autres
parfois les mêmes font des conférences
ou des formations sur le sujet écrivent
des livres et sortent donc du
divertissement pour quelque chose de
plus on va dire complexe d'où sûrement
cette forme de définition multiples que
je défends aussi et qui donne ce
personnage ambigu que le mentaliste
on comprend aussi quelque chose que j'ai
déjà dit à peu près dix mille fois dix
fois disons mille fois alors que j'ai
dit mille fois en vidéo et en interview
les mentalistes que nous sommes nous
nous auto proclamant il n'y a pas de
définition figée pas de pas d'école pas
de formation on est autoproclamé
mentalist ce qui veut dire que nous ne
sommes pas des spécialistes au sens par
exemple d'un diplôme issus de d'études
spécialisé dans un domaine
c'est pour ça que ce serait étrange et
les limites du sérieux qu'à mentalist
soit consultant pour la police par
exemple ou d'autres domaines sensibles
dans ce cas autant s'adresser à un
spécialiste du domaine recherché alors
pourquoi mentalist parce que c'est un
mot pratique comme un sac qui permet de
réunir des passions des techniques de
tout à chacun dans un mot identifier ce
qui évite une longue
explications tous les mentalistes ont
une définition à eux mais également à
l'univers de mon côté mon univers il est
plutôt qui moderne pas mal pédagogique
le tout enveloppé d'humour quand c'est
devant un public comme en spectacle mais
qu'en est il de nos invités
personnellement je me définis pas comme
un mentaliste proprement dit je fais des
tours de mentalisme mais je suis plus
comme un illusionniste généraliste donc
je touche à toutes les branches de
l'illusion et je dirais que ma
spécificité c'est beaucoup le caractère
scientifique de mes numéros
j'ai un cursus scientifiques
d'ingénieurs physicien en fait tu es mon
bagage scientifique inspire énormément
les numéros que je crée donc je crée des
numéros en utilisant des principes
scientifiques mais connu par le grand
public et je les présente aussi dans ce
contexte là sacré del myre où je pense
relativement unique du moins c'est ce
que j'essaie de présenter au public
d'ailleurs dans le monde de la magie on
m'appelle le scientifique pour cette
raison dans lé spectacle de mentalisme
que je joue au théâtre j'aime apporter
une touche poétique et raconter une
histoire par exemple dans mon dernier
spectacle songe d'un illusionniste
je parle de ce qui se passe dans notre
cerveau lorsqu'on dort je parle de nos
rêves de nos cauchemars et je devine les
pensées du public leurs rêves leurs
cauchemars tout en faisant cela
j'évolue dans un décor inspiré des
surréalistes et de magritte
j'aime plonger le public dans un espèce
de cocon qui va les embarquer dans une
histoire interactive finalement et à la
manière d'une réalisation de cinéma
j'aime penser certains détails comme la
musique ou comme le décor dans mes
spectacles j'aime bien raconter des
histoires c'est vraiment ce qui
m'intéresse le plus à chaque fois j'ai
c'est d'ancrer les spectacles dans une
époque avec des personnages ça prend
autant de place que le mentalisme en
fait j'utilise le mentalisme pour
raconter des histoires manière très
immersive comme on pourrait le faire au
cinéma ou dans des pièces de théâtre
voilà c'est ça qui m'intéresse aux
pistes les amis je crois qu'on y est
nous avons donc maintenant une
définition du mentalisme qui pourrait
être un mentaliste est quelqu'un de
curieux et qui utilise l'adjectif
mentalist pour se qualifier sans
adoubement particulier ils rencontrent
souvent la première fois cette
discipline par le biais de
l'illusionnisme soit pour faire un tour
qui semble être du mentalisme on
pourrait appeler ça de la magie mentale
soit pour faire du mentalisme sans
artifice comme les démonstrations de
mémoire que je peux faire une interview
par exemple les centres d'intérêts des
mentalistes leur permet de piocher dans
des domaines
varié allant du spectacle à la
psychologie pour en extraire ce qui leur
est utile afin de pratiquer des métiers
liés à leur statut de mentalist quand ce
métier et la scène ils utilisent en
général tout un faisceau de méthodes
dont le premier but et de bluffer
l'audience de les divertir de les faire
voyager dans un univers et parfois de
leur transmettre quelque chose que ce
soit un message une technique ou
simplement des émotions quand ce métier
est autre chose que le divertissement
mélenchon grossièrement les conférences
les formations et les livres etc
alors le mentaliste se place comme étant
un initié confirmés qui peut utiliser ou
transmettre une partie choisit de ces
techniques dans le but de les appliquer
à quelque chose de spécifique qui sera
utile au grand public car ces derniers
pourront se reproduire
voilà ça fait une longue définition abat
clairement
moi j'aurais dit un mentaliste c'est un
mec qui fait du mentalisme et tu aurais
fait du minimalisme c'est pas bête le
hic je voudrais remercier vivement
victor luc rémy et clément d'avoir bien
voulu jouer le jeu en participant à
cette vidéo encore une fois c'est la
première fois que les cinq personnes je
me compte dedans aussi initier à cette
discipline se réunissent pour en parler
en même temps et je pense que cette
vidéo peut être une référence sur notre
domaine
alors évidemment vous pouvez rencontrer
mes quatre compères et je leur ai
demandé comment alors vous pouvez me
retrouver au théâtre de la tour eiffel
avec mon spectacle s'appelle mentale
circus jusque fin mars
et puis en tournée aussi un peu partout
vous avez toutes les dates soit sur mon
instagram sur facebook ou sur mon site
internet viktor vincent point fr vous
pouvez me retrouver en tournée avec mon
spectacle son jeune illusionniste toutes
les dates sont sur les réseaux sociaux
et vous pouvez me retrouver en librairie
avec mon livre je sais ce que vous
pensez aux éditions larousse d'ailleurs
je suis en tournée un peu partout au
québec pendant toute l'année 2020 et je
veux être en tournée en france dans
quelques pays francophones auto à la fin
de l'année 2020 ou si au début de
l'année 2000 21
d'ailleurs je vais être en résidence à
paris au casino de paris du 21 au 31
janvier 2021
justement il m'arrive de faire quelques
conférences en francophonie sur ces
sujets là mais l'on peut également nous
retrouver dans mon spectacle mentalisme
une affaire du 19e siècle pour lequel je
prépare actuellement une tournée dans
toute la france
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
vous pouvez lalique et durant les
dernières secondes qui nous restent
ensemble ainsi que prendre une seconde
pour vous abonner si c'est pas encore
fait surtout au tibet la cloche activer
la cloche pour être sûr de pouvoir les
prochaines vidéos
c'est la quatrième en quatre ans titré
de la
finition du mentalisme je pense donc que
sera sera que ce sera la dernière
ouais exact à très bientôt
ciao